wake up by 3: to 4:00
a.m. Al that makes us
[Music]
sleepy I've just finished with another
day of medical school currently I'm on
general practice or Americans call it
family medicine and we finished a lot
later than usual when I'm on this
rotation it's currently 1620 and I'm
waiting for my train back up
[Music]
exor Central exor St
David so my journey including the train
ride and walk back home takes half an
hour it's enough time to listen to a few
Medical School voice notes or catch up
on a podcast interestingly during my
commute I feel feel a strong sense of
responsibility to spend my time wisely
maybe it's because I know I'm already
disadvantaged against people who doesn't
need to travel daily to work or school
so I make an effort to do something
beneficial for myself and when I get to
rest at home it feels so much
better it's already so dark outside
[Music]
how was your day uh good it's actually
quite nice sometimes a bit slow but we
had some recognized teaching we swabbed
ourselves and put it on an AAR plate and
we're going to see what grows so that's
kind of fun wow you're in microbiology
are you a little bit cold outside but
actually it's really cold I was freezing
on the way back from the hospital it was
so cold okay I think I'm ready see you
later
[Music]
[Applause]
seconds I'm usually starving by the time
I get home I grab a snack to have enough
energy to get my dinner already which is
quite quick usually because my meal prep
on the weekend to save
[Music]
time
honestly my first instinct when I come
to my room is to lie on my bed but I've
been trying to turn that instinct into a
reminder to quickly unpack and clean out
any rubbish in my bag or Pockets when I
skip unhelpful habits and do something
good as soon as I get into my room it
sets a positive momentum and makes it
easier for me to tackle the rest of my
evening
[Music]
tasks
[Applause]
hello
hi I usually eat dinner right after I
get home which is around 4: to 500 p.m.
and I aim to eat at least 3 hours before
bed and since my flatmates have their
meals past at: I don't see them much in
the evenings as I'm already asleep by
then and you know this can be one of the
disadvantages of going to sleep early
but all of my flatmates are medical
students and we all have 8:00 placements
the next morning so we don't really have
time to hang out much in the evenings on
weekdays
[Music]
anyway it's nice and
home I get very sleepy a lot earlier in
the evening than most people do so I
sleep by 8:00 p.m. and wake up by 3: to
4:00 a.m. I'm not sure which one started
the cycle for me first whether waking up
early caused me to feel sleepy earlier
in the evening or vice versa but I know
this has been my routine my whole life
I'm aware that my natural circadian
rhythm or my body's internal clock sits
on the earlier side of the spectrum but
everyone is unique and what really
matters is how we spend our time not
when we sleep and wake up I am a lot
more paent in the morning so I do
majority of my work then in the evenings
I just prioritize resting but
realistically there are still some days
where I study in the evenings like if
it's exam season but I find keeping
evening work very minimal and doing it
as soon as I can works the best because
the more I push it further the more
sleepy and less productive I get in one
of the skillshare classes I watched on
how to beat procrastination it talked
about reducing what makes doing that
action inconvenient like when we're
sleepy doing anything becomes
inconvenient by the way skillshare has
classes on variety of topics from
freelancing to self-development to
marketing to how to take your crochet to
the next level it guides you step by
step on how to develop a new hobby or
how to turn that hobby into earnings and
the best part is skill share offers one
month free trial so you can access all
of these incredible courses without
paying anything and if you feel it's not
for you you can cancel your subscription
within the trial so it's risk- free
thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
part of the video the first 500 people
to use my link will get one month free
trial of skill
[Music]
share
I amim to do my skin care at least an
hour before bedtime so it gives the
product enough time to absorb properly
so I don't wipe it all off on my pillow
but I try to still time it close enough
to sleep for lower cortisol levels
because research suggests low cortisol
helps with effective nighttime skin
repair by the way cortisol is a stress
hormone in our body that naturally goes
down as we prepare for sleep
[Music]
hello
it's funny my mom had some reservations
towards me sitting in a red room and
just getting on with my evening because
you know historically red is associated
with evil and negative things for the
reason I switch my LED lights to warmer
colors like yellow and red is because
they are less disruptive on our Cadian
Rhythm compared to blue lights so it
helps with melatonin production in our
body the hormone that makes us
[Music]
sleepy